now to a disturbing piece of video
getting a lot of attention online a man
was shot and killed by a police officer
outside a convenience store in
Huntington Beach California on Friday
morning the violent confrontation was
captured on a cell phone camera and then
shared on social media Lee Cowan has
more a witness captured this cell phone
video of a Huntington Beach police
officer wrestling with a suspect while
trying to subdue him it took place
outside a convenience store however the
officer was not responding to a radio
call for help we're not sure why the
officer was out here yet the suspect
immediately struck and assaulted our
officer multiple times grabbed at his
gun belt
the officer was attempting to retain his
weapon slowing down the video you can
see the suspect grabbed something from
the officers belt there was a struggle
for his gun belt at some point the
officer was able to create some distance
between him and the suspect and then an
officer-involved shooting occurred
multiple shots can be heard the suspect
who did not have a weapon later died
from his wounds though the officer was
wearing a body camera the chief wasn't
sure it was turned on however he did
confirm non-lethal force was attempted
several times just because the person
didn't have a weapon if he's struggling
with that officer actively assaulting
that officer and trying to take his
weapon away trying to take equipment
from his belt that can harm him he has
every right and every responsibility and
we train them to defend themselves with
lethal force police caution against
drawing conclusions from the videos
posted online as they are only portions
of the confrontation they're gathering
additional videos and speaking with
witnesses the officer has been placed on
administrative leave
for CBS this morning Lee Callan Los
Angeles